but one of the things that's come up
chris over the course of the last week
or so basically
that aaron rodgers should be happy where
he is that the team around him is better
than
than people
would otherwise say that it is and that
maybe the grass isn't any greener
somewhere else and maybe aaron rodgers
is one of the reasons why they only have
one super bowl over the past 16 years so
let's take a closer look position by
position
at the packers roster and and and then
we'll give it an objective fair
assessment
as to whether or not this team
is is holding him back from being a guy
that has more pelts on the wall or on
the horse depending upon what your
preferred iteration of that statement
would be let's start with the receivers
they've got devonta adams alan lazard
marquez valdez scantling amari rogers
the rookie economy of saint brown devin
functions who opted out last year and
then at tight end robert tunian and
mercedes-lewis where does that group
rank and i look it's there's no
calculator you can punch numbers into
and
and get a reliable answer but just
looking at that entire group where are
they top third middle third lower third
of the nfl i i mean this is like you
know
it's it's pretty easy really when you
break it down and we're gonna do it
right here it's average it's an average
group it's in the middle third in the
middle of the middle third of
football that's what it is i mean listen
we can sit who who are we writing home
about who we i mean yeah devonte adams
okay
everybody else is solid do you want me
to name all the other teams with more
dangerous weapons at receiver than the
green bay packers because it's easy i
can do that oh no marquez valdez
scanling's coming to town with his 33
receptions oh no defenses are quivering
in their boots oh my gosh
and i mean not to disrespect these guys
but like i'm really trying to as you
disrespect no i'm disrespecting the
idiots on social media who are trying to
go like oh the team around them is
pretty special oh yeah all nine
receptions for 67 yards in both playoff
games from davonte adams wow nobody
double teamed them i mean what what like
that's where the people are insane with
this these are rogers haters coming out
you said what you want rogers being a
baby or whatever else all those type of
things you can't realistically look at
this group and have a clue about
football and sit here and tell me you
think that's a top ten group in the
league let alone you know top five or
special or very green grass group get
the hell out of here with that
haven't we seen on multiple occasions
that devonta adams comes out of the
gates having a big game and then the
defense pivots to taking him away
and
and that's it well he's a good you take
you take him away and what do they have
well yeah and he's a good receiver but
he's not a great receiver again when
chris sims does his top 10 receivers
rankings this year again he will not be
in the top five he will not he's really
good i messed up last year he should
have been in the top ten but somewhere
around seven eight nine or ten he's not
the kind of guy that like jalen ramsey
is like oh no i'm in trouble this week
no he's like no i got it don't worry
guys yeah he might catch some passes
where they run a few picks for him and
he gets a six yard completion when i'm
in man-to-man but whatever he's a really
good route runner his greatness is
predicated on a guy that throws laser
beams that stick on his numbers
everywhere that's the greatness of him
but you go through the rest of the group
mike and again robert tunyan there's a
lot of good there i like it scantling
has a role but it's all a role that is
predicated on rogers being amazing that
makes them good that's where i just
won't go go off of it and mike i mean
listen here let's just real quick like
real quick just for the exercise because
all the people out there because i saw
it too oh his weapons are better than
you're giving them credit for okay here
we go not as good as kansas city not as
good as buffalo not as good as the
vikings really not as good as arizona
not as good as tampa bay not as good as
the raiders questionable with the
chargers
questionable with the colts rams are
better um cowboys are better 49ers are
better browns are better seahawks
steelers are way better that's not even
like i'm not i'm not even there yet
that's of course they are the the
seahawks would dk and lock it it's close
they're top two is better than green
bay's top two i know that okay so
they're better all right let's get
carolina panthers better miami dolphins
with waddle now probably better broncos
better steelers like you said better i
mean i i was wrong i shouldn't have said
the middle it's the bottom third of the
league that's what it is it's the bottom
third shut up twitter
you you feel strongly about this i do
because once the more you unpack it and
think about it you go it's absolutely
insane that people are even trying to
make the argument that it's a special
team it's a special group around him
bullcrap during during the break check
your right ear i think some blood is
trickling out of it i'm not sure that
that would be a major cause for concern
though but uh you
you you you turned purple there for a
second okay bruce arians wearing a
purple shirt we've established bruce
erin's has chameleon powers whatever
keller's shirt right he's wearing is the
cut yeah you were the color of the
bricks uh for a little bit so
nothing pisses me off more
when
like
on like i don't even know what i want to
say like hate that has no business being
thrown in one spot on somebody can piss
me off board even the people i don't
like if you start to talk like that i
don't care i'm gonna start going that's
wrong no i mean and that's i just can't
take that aspect of it like seeing that
over the last few days on even on tv and
everything else
you made a point that reminds me of an
old sports debate from the days when
your dad was playing and it was the
jerry rice joe montana who made who
whom who made whom i guess would be the
right way to say it if we're being fancy
but you know is it rice is it montana
montana delivering the ball between the
eight and the zero when rice was in full
stride didn't hurt matters of course i
and and as it relates to rogers
yeah devonta adams runs down the field
and there's the back shoulder throw that
it's just right there and the defensive
back has no chance you don't have to get
open right if rogers trusts you to catch
it if he puts it right where it needs to
be so
how much of adams
is from rogers and how much would adams
thrive or not thrive with a different
quarterback and you know is it and i
don't want to disrespect devante adams
yeah he's real good
right and pop another guy in there does
that guy become devante adam i don't
know about that but i don't think the
drop-off would be as like severe as
everybody thinks you know
receptions fantasy football things like
that
you know and just all the those stats
are make people overvalue players in
general i mean that's just what happens
but no to me of course adams is really
good he's a real good route runner he's
not a top five receiver because top five
receivers to me are guys that like make
defenses have to change and go wait we
can't play this guy man-to-man or we
can't play these coverages and that
doesn't take place with davonte adams
again you know the route running is nice
but it's still all like predicated oh
run a slant route oh rogers throws it
right underneath his chin he gets to run
full speed with the quickest release and
like the the fastest ball thrown through
the air so he's got all that time to
catch the ball accurately react do all
that hey up field back shoulder throws
like you're talking about hey slant
again slant again pick play pick play
hey they're starting to get over the
slant fake the slant oh now he's up the
sideline let me throw a laser before the
safety gets over there bam so yes to me
adam's real good not top five good
somewhere between six and 12 good but
get looks like he's top five good
because he's got a quarterback that's
number one good and that number one good
makes number nine look
top five to me that that's that's how i
would at least say it in my assessment
sorry and this also this also further
underscores the chronic failure of the
packers to devote high round picks
on receivers especially a first rounder
and last year the decision to trade up
and take jordan love when t higgins
michael pittman
leviskus channel
kj hamler chase claypool
chase could you imagine chase claypool
yeah on the green bay packers with aaron
rodgers
that would have been that would have
been the game changer
think about it
i and i there's a story out there that's
never been reported because mike thomas
does a great job of keeping this stuff
internal they didn't use chase claypool
the way they should have used chase
claypool i'm not saying he could have
had a randy moss type of an impact
on the nfl last year if he'd been fully
unleashed but we won't know because he
wasn't fully unleashed yeah if he'd have
been drafted by the packers and fully
unleashed with aaron rodgers at the
quarterback holy crap chris i know holy
crap he's he's
he's a difference maker i mean he's a he
is a guy that yes you have to go wait
you know do we want to play this guy man
to man and do this because he could run
right by us for an 80 yard touchdown
catch a slant run for 80 yard touchdown
he's he's a special entity so i asked
you you heard me you know blabber all
that stuff and everything where do you
think it kind of lies with this group do
you think i'm going too strong by saying
my bottom third or do you think around
the middle of the league is proper
i think when you factor in the quality
of the quarterback
it's fair to say bottom third because if
you took the weapons away from most
other teams
and put them in green bay they'd upgrade
when paired with aaron rodgers right and
we we may find out jordan love with
those weapons what it's going to look
like and then aaron rodgers with maybe
the broncos weapons if that happens if
the packers decide to trade him who
knows at this point whether they will
all right the running backs they kept
aaron jones on a long-term deal they
have aj dillon who was a
second round pick yeah last year second
round pick right and dexter williams is
the other running back jamal williams
went to detroit via free agency where do
they stack up
where do they fit whatever metric you
want to say where are the running backs
in comparison to other team's running
backs i i mean this first off like
dylan and dexter williams are not really
even part of the conversation yet i mean
what i don't know what to think of dylan
all 242 yards he had last year running
the ball like so i i wha you know yes i
think there's a power element but i sit
here as a group and go
well
okay
i mean really it's just about ranking
aaron jones that's really what it's all
about we're talking about one guy but
it's one guy that really helps the
offense out and he's so i guess as a
whole
you know aaron i'm going to say top
10-ish
all right that's that's about where i'm
going to go top 10-ish i don't think
aaron jones is a top five running back i
don't know how you feel about that mike
but i think we're probably in agreement
there when you break down running backs
again you know
jones is really good but i'm not going
to put him in the class of derek henry
dalvin cook i'm not gonna put him in the
close of nick nick chubb
um who else am i missing
um
okay so yeah he's he's right around i'm
i'm i feel like i'm missing somebody oh
christian mcavoy
okay uh but but okay so he's around that
camaro
is who i'm missing right sorry so to me
he's on the outside of that group
looking in he's like a sixth or seventh
eighth the best running back in football
but then the rest of the group itself i
can't sit here and go oh they really
helped this is a running back by
committee phenomenal like the 49ers or
the saints or the patriots have had over
the years no not at all so uh i i guess
yeah i'm going to say top 10ish as far
as the group's concern and i think aaron
jones is on the outside of the top five
looking in what about you
1100 rushing yards last year for jones
in 14 games he averaged five and a half
per carry he's averaged five and a half
per carry three of his four nfl seasons
which is pretty impressive 4.6 yards per
carry in 2019
he he only had 201 carries and he had
let me look here another 30 catches so
you know i would expect him to be used
more especially for what they're paying
him now i'm surprised
they paid him what they did because i
don't think he was getting that on the
open market remember he decided right uh
fairly early in the process to stay put
i think it was the day before
was it the day before the market opened
where you could call him it was
something as he was getting closer and
closer where they decided to keep him
and and i think he knew what wasn't out
there elsewhere and as we've said before
running backs tend to get big money only
from the team that they have played for
rarely rarely do you see a team swoop in
and and drop a big pile of cash on the
table for a guy that that plays that
position that hasn't previously played
for that team jets did it with le'veon
bell and proved why maybe you shouldn't
yeah so i was a little surprised they
kept him um i'd say that they're
i'd say
yeah you're right with dylan we don't
know dylan could have become the guy if
aaron jones had left you use the second
round pick on a
you why are you using that that's what
confuses me because there were plenty
you could use the second round pick on
on a receiver not a running back you
don't need aj dylan when you have aaron
jones and and that that's just it's
confusing to me yeah because you can
find running backs anywhere if you're
good at scouting them and it doesn't
take much to scout them every team at
the college yeah look at aaron jones
look where they got him i mean they
didn't spend a first or second round
pick on aaron jones and look what he's
doing for their team to your point yes
i'd say they're middle of the pack
running backs too i you know maybe a
little bit higher than the middle of the
pack i got to give i love you gotta give
aaron jones capacity right to have
special performances and there was at
one point during the 2019 season where
aaron rodgers was pushing for aaron
jones to be an mvp consideration he
tailed off a little bit down the stretch
that year but uh he had 16 touchdowns
rushing in 2019 that's a big year for
him no it is but see this is where i
would argue even with this right like we
talked about the receivers but when
teams play green bay
yeah
the mission has stopped one thing it's
it's stopped number 12 from dicing you
up
let's play two safeties back let's let's
let's try to disguise like we're in the
box to stop the run and then drop back
into coverage because roger's gonna get
them in the right pass play and he's
going to pick us apart so he gets he
gets their offense in these positions to
where
teams
play
past defense because they're more
worried about him and that that lends
itself to great running looks for aaron
jones and company too because like again
green bay is a
good running team but i don't look at it
and sit there and go oh this is like a
great running team they can impose their
physical will and all the great defenses
in football no we don't see that they
kind of feast on the poor and then when
it comes to the really good defenses
they can never really dominate in the
run game it's the same thing go through
it anybody i challenge you last few
years go through the games really good
defenses run game disappears you know
average to below average oh aaron jones
stats and the run stats are great
because they're so worried about having
to stop rogers in the pass game it just
lends itself to big runs so
uh that's where i argue against you know
the social media crowd and that
department as well
the good news for the packers if there
is any in this regard aj dylan was
drafted after
the second round receivers that i
rattled off earlier they could have had
in lieu of of jordan love so uh it's not
like any of those guys were left when
they took dylan but they still could
have had gabriel davis in round three
who ended up being pretty good for the
bills yeah he did last year he ended up
going in round four all right let's move
on to the offensive line they made david
bachtiari the highest paid offensive
lineman in league history he was since
leapfrogged uh after that but still at
the time that was a good contract for
him he suffered though the torn acl in
practice as we got close to the end of
the season
elton jenkins at left guard lucas
patrick at center replacing corey
linsley and who knows where that's going
to go simon stepaniak at right guard and
uh billy turner at right tackle how do
we feel about the offensive line this to
me is one of the more solid groups on
their football team now i mean yeah
they're going to have you know someone
proven commodities in the middle like
with corey linsley last year i would go
oh no doubt this is one of the top 10
offensive lines in football now right
now at this second
you know with bhaktiari coming off the
acl injury and all of that
you know yeah billy turner's playing
right tackle where really he's meant to
play guard that's really what he is you
know
okay for sure
top half of football there's no doubt
top half of football with maybe
potential to even be a little bit better
than that and i will say at the very
least top half of football with
maybe the best pass protecting left
tackle in the game all right so there's
some positive positives there but i
still will go back to kind of what i
said with the running game and aaron
jones like it's a good group it's really
good don't get me wrong but i don't look
at it as going oh they're just like an
unstoppable force that will impose its
will on great defenses no we haven't
seen that to any capacity from green bay
it always goes back to uh they're
running the ball but it they can't
really do it against these great
defenses we gotta have to do it with
rogers winning the game
it's gonna be interesting to see how
they ultimately address the center
position i mean lucas
is projected to move over stepaniak
completely unproven sixth round pick in
2020. they're going to have to tinker
some in training camp to get the right
mix you know you've got the edges
figured out but when you got a pro
bowler in jenkins at left guard
uh do you leave him there he could go to
the middle do you move your right guard
to the middle what do you do either way
you got to backfill if you move your
guards and that's a fairly important
part of the offensive line because the
heat that can come up the middle now
aaron rodgers can still move but if you
get that that high pressure up the
middle
you got to move a lot more quickly than
you otherwise would because it's going
to be in your face before you know it
yeah that's right it affects too many
different things when it comes right up
in your face you know one you can't see
the field as clearly you can't step into
passes that way you know balls can be
tipped which you know you're throwing a
ball over the middle now you got a big
defensive tackle in your face coming up
the middle ball gets tipped most likely
going to be an interception you know
there's just more
there's less ways to avoid it that way
when it's just dominant dominant up the
middle that way but overall i mean
listen i think this is a pretty good
unit yeah they got they got some
questions
and some unproven commodities but uh i
do look at this as being
surely one of the positive things about
the team
and josh meyer is clearly a factor in
all this he was that's right
he could end up being the center if
they're comfortable letting him be
the week one starter either way you're
going to have some unproven guys on the
field for the green bay packers in 2021
and the center position fairly important
fairly big decision as to what they do
assuming that aaron rodgers is there
because that's the guy who uh is making
a lot of the calls adjusting the
protection and keeping aaron rodgers
from having guys in his face that would
force him to run and hey we've seen him
get injured in the past when you know he
holds the ball just a little bit longer
to let the guy spring open and it sets
him up for
that hit that uh you know as he gets
older and older could be a problem so
where do we put them you got him top
half yeah i'm gonna say top half right
i'm going to say top half maybe with the
potential to be you know on the outside
of the top five looking in that way but
yeah i think that as far as i can go as
top half right now bakatari coming off
acl billy turner right tackle we're not
sure who the center is right now and he
got a new guy playing right guard yeah
that does not say top five or top ten
offense alignment when you just say it
just like that
i i'll say top half with that asterisk
because of bhaktiari's health yeah and
it is it's not quite as work in progress
as the steelers that we talked about
earlier right but there is that
that
hey you know we're we're really not
quite sure and that's another reason why
aaron rodgers at this point in his
career
you you don't embrace the prospect of an
offensive line where we're really not
sure what it's going to be all right the
defensive front seven
um
with zadaria smith and preston smith the
big free agent acquisitions from a
couple of years ago zadaria smith has
done well preston smith has kind of
tailed off you've got rashaan gary who
you know
where does he really fit when you
consider what the smiths do
uh and uh plenty of other guys there
where do where do we put them in another
person another confusing pick rashaan
gary i mean you designed preston smith
and zadaria smith the free agency and
you draft rashaan gary in the top 10.
they play the same position
so
in the middle ish is where i'll put
their front seven
in the middle-ish that's that's about
where it is there's only two guys you
worry about when you play green bay in
the front seven there's two guys
it's kenny clark and zadaria smith you
know yes there's some other good there
but nothing special
right so that would be the big thing i
look at and you know hey look at you
know you look at the defense takeaways a
lot of that a lot of the times is caused
by what the front seven pressure on the
quarterback hit the hit the quarterback
as he's throwing oh the pocket's
collapsing he can't throw the ball quite
the way he wants to errant pass
interception you know that speaks to
that too there just that graphic but
yeah i look at it that way you said it
preston smith was underwhelming last
year rashawn gary they're trying to find
a spot they got a few other guys that
you know are solid players but
not the difference makers that you look
at some of the top defenses in football
have so that's where i just go kind of
in the middle-ish
yeah i
you know they gave us that
that
sense
the year that they went out and got the
two smiths yeah two years ago it was
more special
it's like yeah okay here we go right
here we go let's go the defense is
finally going to be
dramatically better yes until it wasn't
until until
the nfc championship both nfc
championship games they've been
outclassed
they and remember when zadaria smith
told us and this is a deeper issue that
goes to
coaching
leadership
and this is where you could arguably
pull aaron rodgers
into the zone of blame yeah
when zadaria smith tells us candidly
refreshingly but also very troublingly
that when they went to san francisco for
the nfc championship game we weren't
ready to play
and smith said i wasn't ready to play
how how
how does that happen
you're you're a game away from the super
bowl
how in that you may not be good enough
and somebody's going to win and
somebody's going to lose how in the hell
are you not ready to play and where is
aaron rodgers in that
equation because i'll tell you what
the buccaneers
in the 2020 nfc championship game were
damn ready to play y in part because of
tom brady and they were damn ready to
play against the chiefs in super bowl 55
why because tom brady was texting him
every damn night we will win
so
that's that's something that we'll never
really fully truly know and i think part
of it too is it reminds me of when
emmanuel sanders i think it was
ended up in denver with peyton manning
yeah it may have been
and said wow i didn't realize the
difference between ben roethlisberger
and peyton manning until i got a chance
to play with peyton manning and maybe
some of these guys don't understand what
it's like to play with tom brady until
they play with tom brady and how he
takes over the team and he makes sure
everyone's ready to play because i
guarantee you there there have probably
been few playoff games in tom brady's
career where his teammates would say
after the fact we weren't ready to play
no i mean that wouldn't exist it
wouldn't exist now you know again yeah
brady is he's a great leader he's one of
the greatest we've ever seen there's no
doubt about that but again too
you know he was in a spot where he got
to grow into that and the culture wasn't
all put on him and everything like that
you know here it just it's not the same
in green bay that's where it's a little
different you know and again you say
what you want about the guys being ready
and all that we're talking about the
front seven on defense you know brady
didn't have to get jp and sue and devon
white ready they're ready they're ready
you know obviously there is an issue
there with green bay and it shouldn't be
on the quarterback that's extra benefit
sure brady brady's i'm not going to
argue that definitely got an advantage
over aaron rodgers in that department
leadership control of the locker room
the message he could you know sends to
the world whatever all that totally um
but
uh there's there's more issues with the
team itself that rogers has to deal with
as compared to brady that's where i
would say that's a little different for
me
won't it be interesting to see the
stories that emerge from the packers
if and when rogers is traded because i
guarantee you once he's gone there will
be
a torrent of reports and and i think
it's it'll be unfair because it it may
become a feeding frenzy of all the ways
that rogers kept the team from being as
good as it could have been all coming
from the packers once he's traded once
he's no longer there i expect there will
be a ton of news items about the things
rogers did i'm sure to keep the team
from winning the things he didn't do
that tom brady would do to make the team
better i guarantee you that's coming if
and when rogers is i would think so yeah
yeah
i'm surprised it hasn't happened yet
but yeah
they're still hoping to get him to stay
on the team all right the secondary jair
alexander kenny king
eric stokes darnell savage adrian amos
where do they fit well listen i think
that's one of them it's a pretty damn
good group like to me
i don't know if i'm gonna i'm gonna
top 10 for sure i'll say that much i
mean jair alexander is a guy we don't
really talk about enough he is one of
the best pure cover corners in all of
football kevin king crapped his bed and
crapped down his leg and pissed his bed
and down his leg in the nfc championship
game we know that but overall it's a
pretty solid empire yeah i mean pretty
overall he's got a lot of positives
safety plays good you know so i look at
their secondary as being one of the
better things about their team they got
a little versatility they can play man
zone do all of it but what we've come to
really with all these positions is the
green bay packers are
a middle of the road type team that we
look at and we think they're a super
well contender because of one guy that's
the one thing this exercise has proven
to me
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports